mrs. Karen Walker she's been missing for
the past five days have you checked the
bars pharmacies dispensary yes
distilleries speakeasies strip clubs I
think if there was a theme for last
season it was the more things change the
more they stay the same
but now that we've done that now we need
to switch it up Gracie's real here
[Music]
this season so far for all four of us
there's change in the air Kieran is
getting a divorce from Stan grace has
decided to enter politics either you say
she sounds single and ready to try too
hard will finds new Colin he starts
teaching hello this is will Truman
teacher and my character jack is heading
for a wedding with his partner Stefan
yes I'm shaving no not those not those
no not those we've got so many great
guest stars Matt Bomer Jon Cryer Chelsea
Handler Alec Baldwin Charlie was it
anger or foreplay and last night we shot
the first episode with Grace's new
boyfriend
[Applause]
just playing at the level of this cast
who are at the top of their game it was
kind of like this great wonderful gift
we hate all the same things TV and taxis
I read get the worst I think the fact
that people can turn on the TV and they
could visit literally their friends from
years gone by it makes them feel like
this is a safe place I know I'm gonna
laugh the secret is out everybody knows
I'm dyeing my beard nobody thinks that
grace is a natural redhead I think as an
actor if you can make yourself laugh
it'll bring joy to the audience as well
lots of people have jobs where people
are laughing at them but they're not
supposed to be
[Music]